someone didn't do their jobs maintain
these steps my favorite is Franklin
because it also looks awful but then the
glasses but no the glasses make it I
think
[Applause]
hey everyone welcome back to potato mode
and welcome back to part 2 of our
Bioshock double feature last week we
took a dive down to rapture and now
we're heading to the skies to Colombia
with BioShock Infinite so right now I
got everything down to about the lowest
things that can go and then I messed
around with the the texture settings
quite a bit we're not down at the the
fullest potato but we're down pretty low
we're pretty low so we're pretty low so
we got whoa I got a stained-glass window
beautiful me it's like it's like a pixel
art then they added that really gross
blurry filter yeah and it just looks
it's like from what the the Chrono
Trigger re-release on basically gross
I'm just gonna take these offerings cuz
everyone's dead oh oh it's the water
water down the stairs don't look right
though it's like too thick that's weird
his hand looks normal faces are looking
so great it's just they've been turned
real low yeah he looks a little bit more
wrinkly or he has like some of the
wrinkles but they're all like kind of
flattened out dude see the seam on his
hair look it alright oh don't go in
there
alright we got our nice presidents here
founding fathers good old Ben Franklin
in the reflection like if you just look
at the reflection look up to
mm someone didn't do their job maintain
these staff my favorite is Franklin
because it also looks awful but then the
glasses but no the glasses make it I
think bad when your eyes looks pretty
good I think that's because like most of
those textures like in the distance
they're still okay like if they're if
the textures aren't fully there yet yeah
the UM like the textures that are
clearly flat of the city though those
look rough the ones that like the clouds
won't but yeah the ones that look like
clouds but are actually not clouds
the rest is not bad though you can
actually read the signs
I always loved how like this shots would
like float in in it yeah what happens if
your shot floated away though no I think
once you go in there maybe it just
doesn't move oh I meant just like in
like one day a draft just blows away Oh
like I guess a job every day pilgrims
welcome Hudson's some kind of shop oh
boy let's close it just been burned in a
fire burned or eaten by moths all right
we got a lot of bloom happening right
now oh yeah I think the game just kind
of took the lack of textures as a excuse
to just force more bloom on to us yeah
we can up the bloom
[Music]
there's just a lot of really cool
touches in this yeah I love ya like the
then stealing music from different eras
and I know that I think that was like my
favorite favorite like just moment in
the game when you realize that that's
what happened that's what's happening
all right
these guys dancing they're enjoying it
alright let's lower this game settings a
little bit then alright let's do it
alright it's a little work and this big
square line is even more the Bloom has
now expanded to the entire screen how
about this we'll get to Elizabeth and
then we'll we will call it there yeah
sounds good oh wow we're just going
headfirst into this all right let's so
we have the crows I already have some
guns okay Gold weapons apparently
alright I rather play this game go micro
does even work on like robots so alright
it's a big Red Square there so that
means you destroyed it apparently I
think we should just speed her way to a
yes Elizabeth a green oh we can go look
at yeah what is going on with the sky
well we've never played a game where we
have a skybox that were in the sky with
right let's do this let's go blue nice
tall
[Music]
this I feel like did the did why did me
messing with the sames mess with the
audio mixer wondering the same names it
sounds it sounds like that mummy trailer
Tom Cruise is yelling but nothing else
oh my God thank you for reminding me of
that because that thing's like the most
that's the funniest thing I've seen like
that entire year it's funny because like
they they upload that onto like their
their official Channel right it's like
it was like the I'm at the IMAX John's
like IMAX trailer I don't know where to
go oh oh here we go can't wait for the
next Bioshock I'm gonna make one at some
point I imagine there are rumors that
they were like yeah I think it was
something like a kin Lavigne 'less team
which would I don't know how I feel
about that yeah I mean I like Bioshock 2
and he didn't really work on that one so
it's possible that's weird
by the way who was it in the office that
said Ken Levine looked like Steve Carell
that's Peter Brown
how's Peter oh okay I kind of like I saw
where he was coming from but I oh no I
would say no he'll let the audience
decide that's all I'll put up here
here's a picture of Ken Levine here's a
picture of Steve Carell are they the
same person you decide okay we got we
gotta get through it fast
oh alright speeding through it yeah well
look at that look at that oh you got
terrible things Wow
bad stuff happening to a little girl no
speakers that's her that's the girl I've
been I need to get she's going to some
major major balding process right now
but a nice tear
well even see the name of the movie
anymore or there's the I think that you
can see the Eiffel Tower in the back
yeah incoming pretty lady
I like how she's the one whose friend
oh she squints it's so oh look at her
lashes they're just yeah it's just like
a bull it's a little this big blob it's
a block I can't unsee her bald head
underneath this underneath all the hair
oh it's a way out for us for her hey
well gianluca's get finding the way out
we are gonna end this episode here we
are running out of time sadly but thank
you all for watching before I leave
though I would like to actually start
giving out awards how about that okay
yeah I was thinking of like what kind of
award with a potato mode have I was
thinking like a golden tater so I think
I think this episodes golden tater is
gonna go to Ben Franklin for the ugliest
interpretation of Ben Franklin in form
of that statue that we saw in the game
it's probably my favorite
so congratulations Ben Franklin you're
our inaugural golden tater Award
recipient so enjoy it enjoy your enjoy
your time in the spotlight until next
week because we'll be back next Friday
with another episode of potato mode so
we will see you then whoo I'm so glad we
got to see the songbird crush by the
elevator alright guys thanks so much for
watching see you next time boy
these guys spent about five dollars
total on this float my high school
people would like to run out like
banners but they would use like a JPEG
that they blew up oh yeah Oh Mikey it
looks like that you could show these
people we're not no all right we're good
and we're back in the water here full
circle